PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's do another application.
I leave one thing.
So this is going to be-- but
it's called Landau levels.
And they're pretty interesting.
So it's the problem of solving
for the motion of an electrode
in a magnetic field.
So it's called Landau levels
for the physicist Lev Landau
from Russia that discovered
or did this calculation first.
So you have a mass m charge
q, and the magnetic field
b in the z direction.
We will solve it.
And I think you will find
it pretty interesting.
Well, you will be left with a
little of an uneasy feeling,
I think, at the
end of the lecture,
because the problem
of gauging variance
is so dramatic that the physics
will look a little strange
and a bit unrecognizable.
So let me remind you that
in classical physics,
if you have a
magnetic field, b, you
can have electrons that
perform circular orbits,
and the main property
of those orbits
is that they all run
at the same frequency
called cyclotron
frequency, qb over mc.
So this is just Newton's law,
and the force being v over c
cross b should be
a couple of lines
for you to remember that
particle in the magnetic field
goes in circles with
that angular frequency.
So OK, there's lots of comments
we could make about this,
but let's assume
we're going to solve
for the motion of this particle.
We're going to ignore spin.
Sometimes spin is important.
And when you have spin,
you have a Zeeman effect,
spin in a magnetic field.
So that can change the energy
levels by some quantities.
Let's ignore it for the moment.
It is sometimes relevant.
Sometimes it's not relevant, and
you can easily take care of it.
So again, we're faced
with having to represent
the magnetic field.
So you have the magnetic
field [INAUDIBLE] of a,
and we'll take a solution in
which a this time is minus
by 0 and 0.
Remember, that b is
dx ay minus dy ax.
And therefore this works out.
It has an ax component, the
derivative with respect to y
gives you the magnetic field b.
So what happens to
your Hamiltonian?
Your Hamiltonian is now 1 over
2m px minus q over c times ax
plus 1 over 2m py squared
plus 1 over 2m pz squared.
I will not consider z motion.
It's too simple.
It's not too interesting.
It's just motion, plane
waves in the z direction.
It's not interesting.
All the physics is really
happening in the plane.
It's the idea that
we can constrain
ourselves to have
orbits of electrons
that go like this in circles.
OK.
So our Hamiltonian is here.
Let's write it once
again, 2m px plus
q by over c squared plus
1 over 2m py squared.
In order to solve
a system like that,
it's convenient to see what is
conserved, and px is conserved.
px commutes with
the Hamiltonian,
because the Hamiltonian
has no x dependence.
So h commutes with px.
It doesn't commute with py,
because there is a y in there.
And, OK, so if it
commutes with px,
we can hope for eigenstates,
energy eigenstates that
are also eigenstates of px.
So I will write my wave
function of x and y
as a wave function that depends
on y times e to the i kx x.
And it's already
a little strange.
We're looking for
circular orbits maybe,
and the x dependence is
really a little funny here.
It's almost like plane
waves in the x direction.
OK, well, it's a fact.
It's true.
You could not do that
if you would have
chosen a more symmetric gauge.
You see, if you had chosen
a more symmetric gauge,
in which a doesn't have just an
x component, but a y component.
The y component would
have depended on x,
and then x would-- px
and py, neither one
would have commuted
with the Hamiltonian.
So things would
have been different.
But this gauge is easy
to solve equations.
It's called a Landau gauge.
And let's just explore
what this says.
Trust that if you're
solving the equations,
and you get a legal solution,
it must mean the right thing.
So here, in this solution
here, px is just h bar kx,
and though we can restrict
the action of the Hamiltonian
to that subspace of
momentum, px equal h kx,
we can look at the
Hamiltonian, it
is like looking at the
Hamiltonian for this wave
function, we already
constrain ourselves
to have this kind of momentum.
So the Hamiltonian that
acts on the y function
is the Hamiltonian constrained
to the momentum kx,
and it's equal to 1 over 2 m
py squared, the second term,
plus 1 over 2 m qb
over cy plus h kx.
It's the q by over c plus the
value of px, which is h kx,
and I should square it.
If you look at it
carefully, you see
that this is a simple harmonic
oscillator, Hamiltonian.
There's py squared, and there's
a y where the origin shifted.
It's not just a y
squared, but it's
some sort of y minus y0
at some point squared.
So let's write it like that.
So I have to make it look
like a harmonic oscillator, py
squared plus 1 over 2.
For a harmonic oscillator,
I should have an m here.
So I'm going to have an m
squared in the denominator,
so m.
Let's get the qb mc squared out.
y, I got that out, minus--
I have to put all these things.
Minus h bar kx over--
times the c over qb.
Look at all that.
So we factor out qb over c.
With the m squared
here, and the m--
this is the 1 over m there.
y, and I put two minus
signs, because I always
like to write y minus some
y0, which is the equilibrium
position of the oscillator.
Here, as you pull
the c and the qb out,
you get all these things.
So this is a p squared y
over 2n, plus 1 over m qb
over mc squared y minus y0
squared with y0 equal minus h
bar k xc over qb.
That's it.
That's the system.
One good thing happened already.
While this thing is a little
funny or strange, I think,
at first sight, this
harmonic oscillator
is resonating with
an omega, which
is the cyclotron frequency.
So that's nice.
The harmonic oscillator is that.
And therefore, already,
you know you're
going to get levels that are
going to be separated by h bar
omega cyclotron.
So that classical
cyclotron frequency
is going to separate the
levels, and these levels
are called the Landau levels,
the various Landau levels.
OK, so let's see what this
means, or how it looks like.
For that, let's
imagine a solution.
So how does a solution look?
So here is x and y.
And suppose I take a
kx, which is negative.
This kx is any number
you wish at this moment.
So kx negative
means y0 positive.
So here is the y0 is here.
And the wave function is
certainly the probability
densities independent of x.
So the wave function sort of
has support all over x here.
And it represents an
oscillator in the y direction.
In the y direction,
you're oscillating,
and well, you're going
to oscillate a little.
We know, in particular, is
a length scale associated
with the oscillator.
So let's look at
that length scale.
The length scale on an
oscillator h bar over m omega,
in general.
But now, we have an
expression for omega.
So h bar over m, and
omega is qb over mc.
So this is square
root of hc over qb.
And we're going to call
this the magnetic length.
So this is for an oscillator,
an arbitrary oscillator
takes these values.
So let's call the magnetic
length hc over qb.
This magnetic length.
So that's a nice definition.
And that's roughly the
width of the state.
Imagine you're in
the ground state,
you oscillate from the harmonic
oscillator, the typical length
scale, and in this case,
is the magnetic length.
So in the ground
state, this size is lb.
And that's how your orbit looks.
In particular, y0 has a
simple interpretation here.
y0 is equal to minus
kx times the square
of this magnetic length
is a [? right ?] squared.
So it's minus kx
times lb squared.
And the units work out because
k has units of 1 over length,
and you have a length squared.
So that's y0.
So that's how the orbits look.
Now, you would say OK, so
where are the circular orbits?
Well, they're not
quite so visible here.
You have to do some
work to find them.
And in particular,
what is happening here
is a very strange thing.
I think-- well, I'll
say one more thing.
If you have this as your
harmonic oscillator,
your energies, that may
depend of kx and ny,
those are the quantum
numbers you have already.
Well, this is just a
harmonic oscillator.
So it's h bar, the
cyclotron frequency.
Some people call the
Landau frequency.
Occupation number for
the oscillator times 1/2,
the usual formula for
a harmonic oscillator.
And here is the energy.
And well, you had
the plane wave.
Why don't we have the p squared
over 2m of a plane wave?
It's nowhere to be found.
That doesn't show and doesn't
contribute to the energy.
The mathematics
was shown for us.
So this kind of dependence
doesn't do anything.
It's the absolute
degeneracy, the kx.
So you could construct the
superposition of states
here, using Fourier transforms
in which you somehow
localize this in
the x direction,
by superimposing degenerate
energy eigenstate.
So this is the most important
thing about this Landau levels.
The Landau levels are the
different levels of ny,
so ny equals 0 is the
lowest Landau level.
Then you go ny equal 1,
ny equal 2, ny equal 3.
But each Landau level
is infinitely degenerate
because you can put
different values of kx,
and the energy doesn't change.